the sheen Innovation Center this
facility blew my mind it's over 600 000
square feet six hundred thousand square
feet there must be so many bathrooms in
there for pea breaks yeah that they're
definitely allowed to have yeah I bet
that's something that just completely
escaped them walking around like wow 600
000 square feet it's just so many it's
just like a lot it's so many machines
yeah
where's the bathroom remember that way
we came in on the other side of this
Factory that's the one bathroom it's 590
000 square feet that way and how many
people did you say have working in here
uh one person per square foot
yeah they all use that one bat well
there's a bathroom
I'm sure they'd like to use it they
think about it
but they pee outside yeah this is an
executive bathroom actually